first of two
cubs and the reds from g-a-v-p
trevor bauer gets the ball for the red
light his first four starts he was
basically untouchable gave up only two
earned runs
the entire time so what we've seen from
him so far in seven inning games
well we like what we see ian happ about
ready to dig in
to hard hit one hopper to galvest out on
the grass
one out anthony rizzo comes to play
popped up
another long run for suarez
and just in foul territory he gloves out
number two
javier bios comes up breaking ball hit
it off the end of the bat and pops it up
otto backpedaling but it'll be mustache
coming over the second baseman
makes the catch on the edge of the right
field grass final out of the first
34 years of age you darvish
like bauer on a roll here in 2020.
bottle oh
for his last 18 votto drives one toward
left field
playable for schwarber near the track
angling toward the corner out number one
and that'll bring up nick castiano's
a swing and a fly ball shallow center
out goes baez
in comes hap hap will slide and make the
catch
two outs here is jesse winker breaking
ball strike three called
inning over so the cubs have a man on no
score second inning here is wilson
contreras
contreras drills one on the ground base
hit right center field schwarber was
running with the pitch and the cubs have
met at first and third
and if he's not running that's probably
a tailor-made double play ball
dubs have something going here in a
second here is jason hayward stepping in
on the ground and they'll throw the
second one that's all they'll get
and it'll be an rbi fielder's choice for
hayward
hubs lead one to nothing two down a man
at first
and jason pitmas coming up hopped up by
kepnis
and that ball's gonna land fair hayward
to third
it's a single for kibnes and here is
nico horner
then at first and third he swings the
first pitch flips the fly ball to right
castiano started back now comes in makes
the catch and the side
is retired and the reds have two on with
two out the batter is mark payton here
comes the one
two swinging a high fly ball shallow
right center
back pedaling and calling his kippness
he'll make the catch to end the inning
brett brand two one away anthony rizzo
steps in
anthony with more homers against
cincinnati than he's hit against any
other team
hit in the air to right deep back goes
castigliano's near the walnuts got a
chance
gone a home run for rizzo
and the cubs lead two to nothing with
two shutout innings under his belt
tucker barnhart will lead things off
breaking ball swung on and missed strike
three
garvish notching his third strike out of
the day
and bottom searching for any type of
success
19 straight at bats without a hit he
drives one into right center field
and he does break out otto on his way to
second base
hayward with a nice throw in there to
make it a close play
in with a one out double well that snaps
his 0 for 19.
matches his longest hit list streak of
his career nicholas castigano's the
batter
swaying in a miss strike three sharp
breaking ball got him garbage with
another strikeout
here's jesse winker now walk to linker
and now suarez do up two minute on two
down cubs lead by
two breaking ball swinging a miss strike
three
garvish with another strikeout strikes
out three in the inning he's got five in
the game
and starfish who has been on his game
here this afternoon
that'll bring up galvest chop foul at
the plate
you don't see this too often darvish was
throwing a pitch home
and before he threw the ball his glove
came off
i have not seen that before he's
laughing about it chuckling
so the plot thickens bases loaded two
down
this might be the biggest challenge of
the day for darvish freddie galvez
is ready to step in the first pitch
galvest bounces one slowly toward third
charging
loving his horner throws to first in
time good play nico horner
inning over darvish gets out of it bauer
back out for the sixth sitting at 100
pitches a little old school
anthony rizzo to lead it off driven in
the air deep right field if it's fair
it's going to be a long home run
get out the tape measure long gone for
anthony rizzo
cubs lead three to nothing you garbage
on the mound to at least begin the
bottom of the sixth inning
strike three called right down main
street
strikeout for garbage jeremy jeffress
will try to nail down the save
now winker at first base and the reds
down to their final out
the batter is a eugenio suarez check
swing strike three cubs win the ball
game three-nothing the final
and they'll go for the double-header
sweep